if you're on Instagram by now you've
probably seen the filter that tells you
which Kardashian you are who's it gonna
be
Oh Scott Disick well we aren't the only
ones putting the filter to the test even
the kardashian-jenner czar getting in on
the action sit still on Thursday Chloe
had a little fun with the witch
Kardashian ru filter on her Instagram
story
spits temple okay so she didn't turn the
camera on herself but her one-year-old
daughter Tru played and turns out she's
her older cousin northwest ear north II
but true wasn't the only member of the
famous fan to give the filter a whirl
yep turns out Kylie is her two-year-old
daughter stormy of course it's no secret
that Kylie and stormy are two peas in a
pod we have to leave cookies for Santa
on Christmas Eve you know that the two
gave us all the holiday feels recently
rocking matching pajamas while they made
cookies for Santa do it that's right and
the mom and daughter were totally
twinning for the second year in a row at
the annual Kardashian West Jenner
Christmas party wearing these emerald
green gowns of course last year it was
all about the bling
Kylie's even working on a mommy daughter
makeup collab the beauty mogul recently
shared this pic on Instagram
that's the tiny tot checking out the
plans for her mama's Valentine's Day
collection and if you look closely the
box says stormy but this isn't the first
time stormy has inspired one of Kylie's
collections less than a month after
stormy was born in 2018 Kylie
whether collection then of course there
was this and get out of here and show
you guys her work surprised and shy when
et sat down with Kylie's older sisters
they dished on their sisters viral wake
up song rise and shine I've been singing
this nonce what do you guys think of
this we were laughing so hard even the
other night with her being like how did
this become a thing like this is so
funny to us like all the memes that they
were making so stupid funny I love that
one was like the voice competition and
they were all oh yeah yeah yeah it was
the best man that was the best now do
you get on the phone with each other and
you're like rise and shine today you
were like everyone rise and shine no ice
no dude wake up
rain that way in the morning you do and
he loves it where did this come from did
different mom wake you up with rise and
shine is this a family tradition did she
know no I have my good morning song
which I won't sing to you right now why
are you shy nice day that's it
[Music]